i'm gonna fly through this biden speech
but i really want to hit some points
here that i have not seen
anyone else not other conservatives not
really anybody else talking about this
speech
the biggest mistake
that the conservatives are making here
is that they're calling it a mistake
yes it didn't test very well yes in the
short term it looks really bad for biden
and the democrats the speech was not a
mistake the whole thing
the setting the rhetoric the arm
movements all of it was scripted all of
it was intentional why
why because the people who are who are
deciding joe biden's political
operations think that it will help them
in november and moving forward
this was the most significant
presidential speech of my lifetime it
was not the best
it was not the most virtuous it was not
not the most honest but it was the most
significant
this was
as close to a declaration of war on half
the country as i have ever heard from an
american president ever throughout all
of history
frankly abraham lincoln was was more
accommodating and was softer on the
secessionists than joe biden was on
ordinary conservative republicans
abraham lincoln had malice toward none
in charity for all
joe biden malice for half the country
charity for absolutely nobody
he opens up the speech
by setting the stage he says we are here
in this place
for a reason
i speak to you tonight
from sacred ground in america
independence hall in philadelphia
pennsylvania
this is where america made its
declaration of independence to the world
more than two centuries ago
with an idea
unique among nations
that in america we're all created equal
this is where the united states
constitution was written
and debated
this is where we set in motion
the most
extraordinary experiment of
self-government
the world has ever known
the location is important it's not just
because pennsylvania is a toss-up for
the senate seat though that's part of
why joe biden showed up there the reason
why he showed up here though for this
national address and he says we're at
independence hall this is where america
began this is the home of the revolution
it's because he's calling for a kind of
a revolution
his rhetoric is revolutionary rhetoric
he's saying we need to overthrow the
traditional american system and we need
to take half this country as we will
come to hear in the rest of the speech
half this country is a threat to this
country and we need to ostracize half
this country we need to suppress half
this country and we can't let half this
country have any say over where the
country goes he then there was a there
was a little point that i didn't see
anyone else notice but it shows you just
how radical the cultural revolution on
the left is joe biden it placed his
speech in history in the long march
toward greater liberty and equality
and freedom for all listen to how he did
it
we the people
are burning inside of each of us
the flame of liberty
that was lit here
at independence hall
a flame
that lit our way through abolition
the civil war
suffrage
the great depression
world wars
civil rights
did you catch that one bit in there
suffrage
so he says it lit our way through the
long march for civil rights through
through this through that through the
civil war through the depression through
the long march for civil rights through
this suffrage
suffrage we mean suffrage we've had
suffrage since the beginning of the
country suffrage just means the right to
vote what he's referring to is women's
suffrage during the progressive era in
the early 20th century
but he can't say women's suffrage
he can't say women's suffrage because
democrats don't know what a woman is
i promise you that was intentional this
whole thing was scripted out you never
hear woman suffrage referred to as just
suffrage the woman suffrage movement is
called the woman suffrage movement
except now that the democrats have
completely sold women down the river and
deny that women even exist as a category
of being so now they got to change it to
suffer it shows you how radical that
revolution has become then he gets to
the meat of his speech he says you
conservatives it's not just that we
disagree it's not just that you want to
take our country in a bad place it's not
just even to use obama's rhetoric the
conservatives are going to drive america
off a cliff no they're saying
the
the conservatives by their very presence
by their very existence here in voicing
their political views pose an
existential threat to the country
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not
normal
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
now i want to be very clear
very clear up front
not every republican not even the
majority republicans are maggie
republicans
not every republican embraces their
extreme ideology
i know
because i've been able to work with
these mainstream republicans
but there's no question
that the republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans okay so there he contradicts
himself right he says
listen the mega republicans they're the
threat but they're not the majority of
republicans i've worked with i mean
first of all if you just look at the
polls yes they are the never trump
movement barely exists it is
statistically not relevant at all it's
pretty much just bill crystal and a
handful of his friends that come over
for tea to whine about the last seven
years of conservative politics but the
vast majority of republicans have at
some point in some way supported donald
trump they are mega republicans he's
doing this because he doesn't he doesn't
want to come right out and say half the
country is evil but that is what he's
saying and then he contradicts himself
at the end when he says look he starts
out this these mega republicans they're
not the majority of republicans they're
not the mainstream
but they also dominate the republican
party and control the direction of the
party uh i don't think so you can't have
it both ways right now go to
goodranchers.com knowles regardless of
what this administration calls a
recession americans are worried food and
gas prices are higher than they've ever
been certainly in my lifetime i think
just ever which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers while grocery store meat
prices continue to rise good ranchers
inflation proof model locks in your
price the day you subscribe for the life
of your subscription so i've got to just
pause it there for a second
because it seems unbelievable
yes not only are you getting extremely
inexpensive very very high quality mate
but when you subscribe you just lock in
that price
forever for the whole length of the
subscription by the way you can pause
your subscription for up to 90 days or
cancel anytime you want
you're not going to want to you don't
want to keep it 100 american meat
born raised and harvested in the u.s
goes right to your door their beef is
prime or upper choice
the two highest grades superior
steakhouse quality i just absolutely
absolutely love these guys right now
when you go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles can
wles at checkout you will get 30 bucks
off plus free shipping you can subscribe
to lock in your price and recession
proof your meals for life that's
goodranchers.com use code knowles at
checkout and then in this extremely
gloomy ominous speech with the red and
the screaming and the you know he almost
slips into a prussian accent while he's
giving it he says
that we need to be optimistic
even in this moment
with all the challenges we face
i give you my word as abide and i've
never been more optimistic about
america's future not because it may be
because of who you are
we're going to end cancer as we know it
mark my words
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which thou canst
not see after this doom and gloom fire
and brimstone we are going to come for
you our political opponent speech
he says but we need to be
optimistic we need and as he says
optimistic right on cue
you hear a siren in the background
because because
the
the very structure of reality will not
tolerate that kind of preposterous
disingenuous hypocritical lie from joe
biden
doom and gloom and pessimism but we need
to be optimistic
i don't things aren't looking too
optimistic joe
and he he
ends the speech
on what i think was the people would
call it a gaff
i would call it a freudian slip
age is still to come we'll say we all of
us here we kept the faith we preserved
democracy
we heeded our word we
we heeded not our worst instincts but
our better angels there it is
we heeded our worst instincts that oh
wait whoops was i not supposed to
oh no no sorry i got confused we heeded
not our worst instincts there it is a
freudian slip where you say one thing
but mean your mother so that was the
biden speech okay red
screaming gesticulations were
half the country's evil and illegitimate
now
coincidentally
donald trump just gave his first public
speech since the raid on mar-a-lago
since the biden administration raided
biden's predecessor and chief political
rival totally unprecedented so banana
republic kind of stuff and so
donald trump gets out there and he gives
his speech to his conservative
supporters
take a listen compare and contrast
fetterman may dress like a teenager
getting high in his
parents basement
but he's a raging lunatic hell bent on
springing hardened criminals out of jail
in the middle of
the worst crime wave in pennsylvania
history
hilarious as the whole speech was
hilarious
notice
donald trump's
red white and blue everywhere joe
biden's just red everywhere
dark red donald trump's red white and
blue everywhere joe biden's very dark
ominous donald trump's big smiley
bright lights everyone
joe biden's everyone yelling and angry
and fear half this country is a threat
to democracy donald trump yeah you see
this fetterman guy he's totally nuts we
shouldn't vote for him you should vote
for the other guy because fetterman he's
going to be a bad politician
which one of those two speeches is more
in line with the american tradition
the biden hall putsch or donald trump
giving a campaign rally which one of
those two speeches
seems like the threat to democracy which
of those two speeches seems on the
lighter side of the battle for the
american soul it's not even a question
and well you and trump is smart here
he's not taking the bait in this obvious
provocation for political violence he's
just laughing his way to november he's
saying look we might have the forces
right against us all right we might have
a lot of stuff to take on not just the
democrats but the whole deep state and
the whole the whole
fetid swampy establishment but we're
just going to keep our chins up we're
going to keep doing the right thing
we're going to we're going to hug that
american flag picture those two images
biden screaming yelling red all around
him donald trump hugging the american
flag kissing the american flag at that
speech during his presidency you got
those two images trump says we're going
to do that that's really going to be the
way we keep the faith that's going to be
the way if we are to keep our democracy
that's how we're going to do it
i'm so glad you like that clip now what
hold up
you got to ring that bell subscribe get
all the notifications that way well not
only have we hit a million subscribers
we're going to hit one trillion make
sure you do it now we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you